[Music]  here we have a trailer this is a trailer  you made with Paul Walker for fast  [Music]  six-letter die  boom if those are my choices I'd rather  choose arrived not truly man are you  gonna sear my taillight I just say  distance I might add I think fender  [Music]  so hold on to that wig but to blow that  thing off  my shan't continue wedding could set  your the striking blue eyes of Sir  Winston Churchill himself from the  theory of the predation exhaust get all  the way over what are you talking about  how do you like your sandwiches cucumber  Oh double cucumber don't you see this is  what a winner looks like and this is  what a seventeenth-century father's done  [Music]  [Applause]  what a good ass it's very stupid